-Enjoy yourself. Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is so exciting.
The former First Lady,
Michelle Obama is my guest
tonight on the show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness.
Earlier today, I texted Michelle
and I got a message that said,
"We're sorry. The number
you reached is totally made up."
[ Laughter ]
It must be weird for Michelle
to not be running for president
and have no interest
in running for president
but also be outpolling everyone
who wants to be president.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's here to promote
her new book called
"The Light We Carry."
It's about how we all
have light within us.
And it's also about
how Joe Biden spent eight years
walking around with
his iPhone flashlight on.
It's like, "I can't -- I don't
know how to turn it off.
Jill! Jill! How do I --"
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's get to some news.
President Biden
and the First Lady
just released
their tax returns,
which show that they made
less money than the year before.
When he heard, Biden
was like, "Friggin' Biden."
[ Laughter ]
Biden's tax returns
were pretty interesting.
Under "gifts received,"
he wrote "nowhere near
what Clarence Thomas got."
[ Laughter ]
-Goodness!
-Then under "dependents,"
Biden wrote,
"I only wear them when I know
I won't be near a bathroom."
-Ohhh!
-That's too much information.
That's too much information.
TMI.
Some news from overseas --
Kim Jong-un said
that North Korea's
first military spy satellite
is ready for launch.
Keep in mind,
a North Korean spy satellite
is just a GoPro
on a tennis ball.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it would be like that
remote control helicopter
you got for Christmas,
you know?
Give it five minutes before it
gets stuck in a tree, you know?
Ah, forget it.
Some business news --
I saw that Google
is about to release
their first ever foldable phone.
Yep. The phone is amazing.
They say it folds faster
than Fox News in court.
-Hey! Ohh! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ka-ching!
-You guys see this?
According to a LinkedIn report,
Amazon is the best company
in the U.S. to work for.
[ Audience murmuring ]
Every Amazon employee was like,
"I love it here"
then blinked
the Morse code for "help."
[ Laughter ]
Amazon is actually a great place
to work, unless you're a box.
[ Laughter ]
Happy Mother's Day.
Some entertainment news --
Netflix announced that
in the coming months
they will roll out paid password
sharing in the U.S.
Paid password sharing?
[ Audience boos ]
Yeah, because that's what
everyone wants to do.
Pay their ex 12 bucks a month.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
Some more entertainment news --
I read that HBO
just started casting
their new TV series
reboot of "Harry Potter."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Believe it or not,
we actually got a sneak peek
at some of the choices
that they've made.
Check these out.
In the reboot,
Harry Potter will be played
by
Jorge Santos.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Lucius Malfoy
will be played
by Marjorie Taylor Greene.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
Here's another. Voldemort
will be played by
Jeff Bezos.
[ Laughter ]
Mr. Ollivander
will be played by
Bernie Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
Here's another. Mad-Eye Moody
will be played by
Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Peter Pettigrew
will be played by
Boris Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
Here's another.
Madame Maxime will be played
by Las Vegas Raiders
owner Mark Davis.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Dobby will be
played by
King Charles.
[ Laughter ]
I'm excited. I think this is
going to be good, real good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of King Charles,
this is exciting.
The official dish of his
coronation has been announced,
and it is coronation quiche.
-Mmm!
-Yep. King Charles actually
released his very own recipe.
-Really?
-Yeah. Here it is. Step one...
There you go.
That's the recipe.
That's how you do it,
huh?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mwah!
And finally, scientists
in New York
just discovered a method to
prevent hair from turning gray.
One guy heard and was like,
"That method is
don't become president."
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.